you
hi everyone is Jerry this is a very
famous endgame composition by Leopold
Metro fond of it is his most celebrated
chess composition it was awarded first
prize in 1967 first prize out of 250
entries he is no stranger to first
prizes of 300 submitted compositions
over the years he received 40 first
prizes and this one again is his most
celebrated composition Tim Crabb a who
is a Dutch journalist novelist and chess
master had the following words to share
about this he regards it as he regards
this composition here as his candidate
for study of the millennium those are
some big words let's see if by the end
of this video you agree with them it's
white to move if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation for white or maybe
just sit back relax and appreciate this
amazing puzzle okay
the solution runs as follows starts off
with b6 check King AAA so that when
white does Queen the bishop will now be
able to block following up we have rook
e1 the first star move of this puzzle
the rook is there to stop black from
queening but the rook can be taken so
what was the point well when black now
promotes to a queen this Knight will
interfere with the Queen's ability to
give checks to the white King or in
other words this rook check is securing
the white King's position the Queen will
not be able to go to e 1 or a 1 to give
check all right so that's nice but it
gets more amazing soon enough g7 and the
main continuation from here will run
with black promoting right away but
before I show that let me just touch on
two variations here ones where we are a
bit disruptive to the white king suppose
Knight c4 on Knight c4 we would play
b5 and now after these guys promote we
would have a seven if the night gives a
check in this position well there's a
night check from here and Queen h2 let
me touch on Queen h2 right here because
we do have this main threat on b8 now
too many options for black on Queen h2
we will have mass exchanges the Queen's
coming off the board and also this night
at the end of the day these three past
ponds are going to be no match to the
black king and Black Knight one of these
guys will eventually push through the
night is tied down to defending the H
pawn and the King helps out pushing
through one of these guys to Queen one
last variation before the main
continuation is at this point right here
after a seven instead of Queen h2
suppose Knight check a knight check we
have king c6 queen h2 to defend the
bishop and now follows pawn takes Bishop
Queen takes b7 check exploiting this pin
King a7 and now it's a matin
with Queen g1 check and then Queen to b6
but getting on with this main
continuation after g7 we have black
promoting white promoting the bishop
blocking a7 what do we do now knight c6
this knight needs to be taken as
otherwise the black queen will be able
to give the white king problem just
pointing out a very simple example of
this I'm King - a6 queen f1 that's
already mate the short story here is
that the night must be captured and now
this is opening up the fifth-ranked
Queen takes h5 check what do we do now
as white if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation from white from this
position
okay the follow-up move here is one that
Victor corrosion in ICC F international
master called a move from another world
do you agree with it the move here is
Queen to g5 you're not going to see this
very often at all in a chess puzzle
we're giving up our queen with cheque
and she's going she's on an unprotected
square it's it's like a free queen what
is the purpose well it's similar to that
earlier Brooke move the Queen is now in
a position where after king a6 there's
not a successful way to give a check to
that white king and if we just take a
moment here to recognize the material
imbalance we have three white pawns
versus a queen bishop and night and it's
black to move we have a mate threat on
b7 and how do you stop that it's not too
many options the best continuation is to
maybe sack your queen but let's go with
this one here Bishop takes pawn first
what's the follow up c7 once again
taking stock of the material count here
Queen Knight Bishop but they are no
match for these far advanced pawns who
are threatening mate b7 mate I may in
one threat with b7 and a matin to threat
with C 8 equals Queen and then Queen to
b7 there's nothing you can do to stop
that you could play here to stop that
pawn from advancing but b7 is mate and
you could play here but after check
Bishop block b7 check Queen takes Queen
takes and that is mate the best
continuation at this point here is to
give the Queen back Queen a5 and after
King takes King b7 but this is only
prolonging the inevitable after pawn
takes Bishop one of these guys will be
pushing through to get a Queen soon
enough if in this position Bishop takes
pawn notice they would simply follow
King takes bishop and million one
what an amazing puzzle feel free to
share what your thoughts are on this
I've never seen a move like this before
this is a puzzle it's regarded as Metro
phenoms deflection this move here Queen
to g5 giving up your queen so as our so
we could simply secure our king position
for a little bit and these two these
pawns here turn out to be too much for
the black side to handle very unique
position very amazing puzzle feel free
again to share what your thoughts are on
it and as always I hope you enjoyed this
puzzle and I'll catch you in the next
video take care bye
you